we have a wonderful morning mustard
here's Olivia Sterns my morning must
read it comes from lean over should ski
and Bloomberg View he is writing
blockupy protests at the ECB tower are
absurd he says quote with garbage
garbage cars and tires burning all over
the place the German financial capital
looked for a moment like keV during last
year's revolution the Frankfurt
protesters were barking up the wrong
tree the ECB is for now the leftists
best friend so we started to see these
pictures on air early yesterday
incredible scenes there in the streets
of Frankfurt fire cars lit on fire 94
police officers were wounded 550 people
were detained this is Frankfurt this is
really wild and Brzezinski point here is
that actually the ECB is the friend of
leftist groups like Tsaritsa because by
continuing to fund Greek banks in fact
they are propping up that party yeah I
wanted the same thing when I saw these
pictures of 10,000 people gather to the
Roman burg that's the the medieval town
square in the center of Frankfurt this
is you know like as Olivia said this is
kind of unheard of this is not very
Frankfurt they should have been marching
on Berlin if they're really worried
about austerity the austerity is
definitely not coming from frankly it is
coming from Berlin was you going on
these are German Germans yes there are
every once in a while you do see you
know a BMW on the street of Frankfurt
that gets its tires lit on fire because
there is sort of a backlash against you
know the ultra-wealthy in Germany but
this is unprecedented 50 people look at
that rah I have never seen riot police
in Frankfurt it's finishing know there
is some solidarity with a far German
left with serezha there was it you know
there were there are protests about a
month ago and I saw sign in English that
read it starts in Greece and then it
comes here it's just fascinating to
watch you know the Far German left we're
talking about this in the last hour tom
has never really disappeared the way it
did in the US there's a very active
anti-nuclear power movement which was
successful in getting Uggla miracle to
change her policies two years ago and
there's there's there's a there's a very
active anti-nato movement in Germany as
well ok so Brendan they are protesting
austerity in Germany are they protesting
austerity in sympathy with the south of
Europe because there are as I'm aware
there wasn't much austerity in Germany
no they are protesting they're
protesting German policies and this is
why
likely an adverse its key I'm confused
that they're protesting the ECB because
the problem is not in Frankfurt it looks
like a WTO meeting yeah I'm just
thinking about protests outside the
echoes building in Washington can get
there I think you're totally right it's
I just thought it was bizarre yesterday
interior point it should have been in
Berlin yes and there's nothing there
this morning to be clear we're not know
nothing has come across our headlines
again ninety four police officers
wounded five Jennifer one rule